for white to win this one black keeps  the opposition like he does here blocks  off the advance of the white king and  we're just going to see a Shuffle by  both Kings here no way no way through  this is end game 101. 9 game is so  tricky but if you know your stuff you  can save a lot of points  yeah this one uh it's so unfair chess  you see the most exciting game roller  coaster game they always seem to end in  draws however and uh King versus King  did you see that Magnus just clapped  applauded Prague and we have a draw  wow that is uh so interesting Magnus  calls and I'm pregnant on that they keep  having the best fights in the mouthwater  Champions chess tour and this one went  all the way down to King versus King a  draw between the 17 year old and the  world number one Magnus Carlsen now we  are oh look at that and Applause does  that what is that about when he's  uploading I think he just loves players  who go for him